The OMS program has a thriving
presence on Google+.
Amazingly, the Google+ community
is entirely student run.
We gather resources, share tips, and
ask questions of our fellow students.
Enormous credit goes to Nate Payne for
setting up the community and
the moderators of the community for
helping to run it.
To access it, go to the link
in the instructor notes below.
The first time you visit, you'll be
prompted with this ask to join link.
Click that to join the community.
After you join you'll find
lots of useful resources here.
The box in the top right
has common resources that
every OMS student will need.
Scrolling down you'll find posts,
links, questions, and
suggestions from your fellow students.
>> There are similar communities on
LinkedIn, Facebook and other sites.
And you can find links to those in
the instructor notes below as well.